[Musique]
le département de la réunion présente
son plan de relance économique et social
avec deux volets d'intervention à court
et moyen terme
le volet de relance à court terme
prévoit 70 millions d'euros
d'investissements mobilisables avant la
fin de l'année il sera consacré en
partie à l'accompagnement des personnes
fragiles et vulnérables à la filière
agricole et à la lutte contre la dengue
il y a cette misère qui frappe notre
territoire nous allons compagne et près
de cent mille cent vingt mille familles
bénéficiaires du rsa des familles qui
sont lourdement frappé par cette crise
nous allons les accompagner dans les
dépenses sociales
je pense au soutien alimentaire en
premier je pense aussi au soutien de
bien-être et de reconstruction parce que
le confinement à impacter les personnes
et nous voulons redonner du lien
nous voulons redonner du dynamisme de
l'an viii de la volonté à travers donc
ses dépenses sociales le second volet de
soutien à moyen terme et mobilisables
pour les cinq prochaines années la
collectivité prévoit d'investir près de
500 millions d'euros pour relancer
l'emploi et la commande publique et là
dedans il ya l'amélioration de l'habitat
nous voulons doubler les crédits
d'amélioration de l'habitat ici à la
réunion passant de 20 millions à 40
millions d'euros par an amélioration de
l'habitat
nous voulons aussi continuer à soutenir
la création de logements neufs à travers
un projet de 30 millions d'euros par an
et bien sûr dans nos compétences à nous
qui sont les routes les collèges les
structures d'accompagnement
d'hébergement pour les personnes âgées
les personnes souvent en situation de
handicap
nous allons même pas de 200 millions
raw ou à soutenir la création donc la
construction de notre territoire
dès le 1er septembre prochain le
département lancera un nouveau
dispositif le rsa plus avec pour
objectif de favoriser le retour à
l'activité de plus de 5000 bénéficiaires
du rsa
ce plan départemental de relance
économique et social est un engagement
volontariste de la collectivité pour
permettre à l'économie réunionnaise et
aux réunionnais de surmonter la crise
multisectorielle ducobu 19
[Musique]